benjamin franklin is well known as one
of the founding fathers of america but
there was another side to this renowned
statesman he was a polymath someone who
has in-depth knowledge of numerous
subjects franklin was a writer publisher
scientist and inventor who continually
reinvented himself benjamin franklin was
born in boston massachusetts on january
17 1706 to candlemaker josiah franklin
and his second wife abaya folger he was
their eighth child and final son he also
had seven half siblings from his
father's first marriage at the time of
his birth boston was already a thriving
seaport filled with sailors merchants
preachers and prostitutes growing up
next to the charles river he enjoyed
swimming and early on the inventor in
him tinkered with ways to glide through
the water more quickly he made his own
version of fins his were two wooden hand
paddles when franklin was six his family
moved from a tiny two-bedroom house to a
larger home in the heart of boston this
allowed his father to entertain
interesting dinner guests which benjamin
later remarked helped to improve the
minds of his children as for his formal
education benjamin didn't have much his
father only had enough money to send him
to school for two years squashing the
expectation of his son going to harvard
in the hopes of eventually joining the
clergy so benjamin's formal education
ended when he was just 10 years old
someone wondered whether he would have
been as great of a scientist as sir
isaac newton if he received more of an
education but what franklin lacked in
formal schooling he made up for with his
passion for reading he even stopped
eating meat and became a vegetarian in
part so he could save to buy more books
his love of reading and writing
flourished further when he worked at his
brother james printing shop as an
apprentice he even got a chance to
publish his own articles for his
brother's newspaper one of the first in
america under the pseudonym mrs silence
do good when he was 17 years old
franklin left boston for new york hoping
to break out on his own and find work as
a printer but he didn't have any luck so
he went further south to philadelphia
which was then the largest city in
america he worked in several print shops
around town and later for a philadelphia
merchant by that time benjamin was tall
muscular comfortable with any company he
kept and very charming he boarded at the
reed family home and fell in love with
15 year old deborah reed deborah's
mother refused to allow their marriage
because he didn't have a penny into his
name he continued courting deborah in
years later he entered into a common
common-law marriage and she ended up
raising his illegitimate son william
whom he had with an unknown woman
deborah and benjamin had two other
children a son francis who died of
smallpox at the age of four and a
daughter named sarah franklin spent his
twenties helping to improve the
community in philadelphia he formed the
junto a club consisting of young men
from diverse backgrounds that met on
friday evenings to discuss morals
politics philosophy and science they
discussed questions like have you lately
observed any encroachment on the just
liberties of the people the junto
meetings were modeled off english coffee
houses which franklin knew well having
worked in a printing shop in london for
a time members loved to read and decided
to pool their money to buy books that
everyone could take their turn enjoying
they created america's first lending
library the library company of
philadelphia franklin later became the
publisher of the pennsylvania gazette
which served as a voice of opposition to
british colonial rule not only did he
print the paper he often contributed to
it like this political cartoon depicting
a snake in pieces called join or die
that was meant to rally the american
colonies together each piece of the
snake represented a colony though there
were 13 colonies yet only eight pieces
because he grouped some colonies
together
he also used his newspaper to write
about his inventions including his
famous experiments with electricity with
the help of his son william he attached
a wire to the top of a kite which picked
up an electric charge from thunderstorms
and conducted electricity all the way
down the white kite string this led to
his invention of the lightning rod which
protects houses from lightning when it
carries the electric charge harmlessly
to the ground without burning the house
down franklin's groundbreaking work on
electricity made him famous that name
recognition would come in handy as he
was tasked with convincing the french to
support american independence he spent
several years stationed near paris as
america's first diplomat his popularity
in diplomatic skills apparently paid off
france sent troops and supplies to aid
the colonies during the revolutionary
war and formally recognized the us as a
sovereign nation franklin was appointed
postmaster general during the war and in
that role was responsible for making
sure mail was delivered as quickly as
possible by horseback that was a crucial
line of communication that held the 13
colonies together despite all the hats
he wore franklin somehow found time to
devise inventions throughout his life he
created bifocal glasses which have two
halves the upper for distance the lower
for reading the franklin stove was a
meadowline fireplace that provided more
heat and less smoke than the open
fireplaces used at the time
one of his more unusual inventions was
his beloved glass armonica he worked
with the glassblower to create the
musical instrument inspired by musicians
who passed their fingers around the
brims of glasses filled with water it
was very popular during his time mozart
even composed music for it if inventing
weren't enough he also had a major
influence on the science of demography
or studies of the population he took
notes on population growth and realized
the american population was the fastest
growing on earth and would surpass that
of england in a century his writing on
the subject was not without controversy
in an essay he wrote why increase the
sons of africa by planting them in
america where we have so fear and
opportunity by excluding all blacks and
tawnys of increasing the lovely white
and red but perhaps i am partial to the
complexion of my country for such kind
of partiality is natural to mankind like
many of his time franklin owns slaves
and viewed them as inferior to white
europeans but in his later years he
became a vocal proponent of abolishing
slavery he also didn't hold other groups
in high regard when there was an
increase in german immigrants to america
he feared it would bring down the
country as the population grew franklin
wrote about the importance of improving
farming practices to meet the booming
demand for food when he retired from the
printing business he bought a 300 acre
farm in nearby new jersey it became his
experimental station where he carried
out projects in drainage crop rotation
and fertilization looks like the
founding father was now a founding
foodie he also introduced many
international foods and plants to
america such as swiss barley scotch kale
chinese rhubarb and silk he was exposed
to international goods thanks to the
time he spent in london on diplomatic
missions he made many trips there from
the 1750s to the 1770s but would later
sever ties to support the american
revolution in fact he had a falling out
with his son william who remained loyal
to britain franklin never forgave his
son for quote taking up arms against me
franklin was part of a committee that
drafted the declaration of independence
which explained why the 13 colonies
regarded themselves as independent and
no longer under british rule he's the
only person to sign all three major
documents that established the united
states as an independent nation the
declaration of independence the treaty
of paris and the united states
constitution after the constitution was
ratified in 1788 franklin wrote to a
scientist friend in france and gave us
one of the most famous sayings our new
constitution is now established
everything seems to promise it will be
durable but in this world nothing is
certain except death and taxes
throughout his middle and later years
franklin was obese and suffered many
health problems he had a long history of
lung disease and gout a form of
inflammatory arthritis that results in
red and swollen joints on april 17 1790
franklin died at his home in
philadelphia when an abscess in his
lungs suddenly burst he was 84 years old
it's estimated 20 000 people attended
his funeral nearly the entire population
of philadelphia at the time today every
year tens of thousands of visitors
tossed pennies at franklin's gravestone
for good luck and not to a famous saying
attributed to him a penny saved is a
penny earned though apparently he never
actually said this he did once right
remember that time is money without a
doubt benjamin franklin used his time
wisely if you'd like to hone your skills
just like franklin did and who knows
maybe become a polymath yourself there's
a great and interactive way to learn
brilliant is an amazing tool for
brushing up on your science technology
engineering and math skills it almost
doesn't feel like learning because
you're having fun while solving
interactive problems their everyday math
course helps you see fractions
percentages and geometry in a new light
my personal favorite is the logic course
which helps improve your critical
thinking skills if you ever get stuck
there are hints to help you out and
explanations if you get the incorrect
answer there are no tests on brilliant
and you can work at your own pace to get
started for free visit brilliant.org
newsthink or click the link in my
description or pin comment in the first
200 of you will get 20
off brilliant's annual premium
subscription which unlocks all of the
courses
thanks for watching for news think i'm
cindy palm
[Music]